Well,
I'm not working today.
Why is your Shawn was with,
we should fail.
It's a great pleasure of my,
a wonderful colleague and great friend,
Bruno Gabon,
ah,
who is going to give the lecture today on the Great War grief and memory.
And he's the author of a really terrific book on called an English,
uh,
victory plunged into morning on what happened at the end of the war to the
soldiers and to France.
And he has just published,
I just received it a a few minutes ago that allow said delight,
wrong gap under his,
uh,
his,
editor ship,
uh,
along with,
any,
uh,
do may need.
Uh,
what else?
Plus the
Doula.
Nice.
John,
this is my pleasure to give this class today on,
uh,
the Great War grief and memory.
As a kind of introduction,
I would like to start with a book as that Sigmund Freud wrote in 1915 photos for
the times on war and death.
And according to me,
this is probably one of the most fascinating works,
original mass death and collective mourning in,
uh,
in during the great whore for described.
And they would like to quote the complete collapse when death has struck down
someone we love,
a parent or partner in marriage,
a brother or a sister,
a child or close friend.
Her hopes,
he says,
the hopes or desires and our pleasures line the grave with them we will not
become sold,
will not feel for lost once place.
Actually mass death and its consequence generalized morning appeared well before
the end of a war.
To give you only one example,
around 50% of a French soldiers killed during the great war,
lost their lives in 17 months periods between August,
1914 and disseminated 15 four years later in 1918 1919.
So in the immediate aftermath of war,
death was basically everywhere.
The names written on war memo oils built in the early 1920s.
The black dresses of the war,
widows,
VMT spaces left by so many young men all over Europe and all over the world.
We all know,
you all know,
uh,
from a demographic perspective how deadly.
The great war was around nine,
9 million Sadia skills.
2 million Germans,
1.8 million Russians,
1.4 million French.
And to the debt of a great war,
one must also add all those killed by pretending to be other Spanish flu,
maybe two or three times more murderous than it will on probably 20 million
people were actually killed by the Spanish flu epidemic in 1918.
So we all move his fingers.
That's according to me.
They mean nothing if one does not consider them in their relationship with
privates and collective mourning.
And that's the topic of today's class.
Studying private and collective mourning is of course,
much more difficult than studying mass death from the perspective or historical
demography because most of the time,
uh,
vis personal,
very personal,
very intimate and family experience of mourning as left,
uh,
as not left many,
many sources.
So the challenge for the historians is actually to grasp the mourning process in
its reality.
Something equivalence to once the German sculptress get to call of it's dead.
When she made VIF to granite statues,
we presenting a husband,
Carl and urself mourning their song.
Peter was killed in Belgium and you have a city of EAP in October,
1914 of course he's talking to nuts captures historians are not artists
unfortunately.
So how do we study privates and collective mourning?
That's what,
that's what I will like to examine that if you in this class,
if the first part of my discussion or like to um,
I mean my perspective will be rather general if you have to buffer for war one
were the people in morning I will ask and how many of them were there.
But otherwise this question touches on the possibility of studying what Jay
winter once killed communities in morning,
a very full proper king concept that he's using mostly for Great Britain and for
the u s if the second part of his class I will examine the specificity of
mourning in the aftermath of war one.
In doing so,
hope to show you that's morning can be studied from a competitive perspective
and that despite their personal emotional dimensions,
we'll bereavements after the great war actually have some characteristics in
common.
And lastly,
I will in my class because I mean even mourning process in itself and in doing
so I would like to study the relationship between personal suffering and
collective mourning.
In other words,
the transformation of grief into a cultural process.
So let's start with my first point.
We're the persons in mourning after war one.
Well from the perspective of historical demography,
his question is actually a very difficult one wine because in France,
Eva Twenties and thirties well we doze remarriages last fair benefits and so
simply vanished from the statistics.
And if you take the case of the orphans,
they got some l from the French state when they were children,
that's not when they came of age.
Consequently,
the number of you'll find in most textbooks of around 600,000 windows and at
least 760,000 orphans in France in the 1920s is of course only a rough estimate.
And this is not to mention for grandparents,
the brothers,
the sisters,
the uncles,
the owns for nephews or cousins were in mourning too and sometimes expressed in
very moving diaries in very moving lecturers in very moving over sources,
their sufferings.
So we can set of communities in morning coined by Jay.
Winter is a very useful one as a means to grasp the scale of morning after we
won in its entirety.
Actually every institution,
every social structure went into mourning in the aftermath of all won the
franchise schools,
the French Lycee,
the French universities,
the French companies,
the French businesses,
as well as let's say the French athletic clubs of the French football teams.
The debt might have the names inscribed in a number of places where schools were
former colleges,
their parish churches,
we social structures with themselves or communities in the morning.
We'll themselves composed of various groups affected by morning in varying
degrees depending on their relationship with the deceased when he was still
alive.
And what's the second notion.
But I would like actually to introduce what the French historian Stephan O'dwyer
whoso once called the circles in mourning for circles of morning.
The first circle for morning was composed of soldiers themselves for obvious
reasons.
On November 11th,
1918,
the French army was not only a victory swan,
but also an army in mourning.
Mourning for dad as much as rejoicing for victory.
What did the soldiers do on armistice day?
November 11th,
1918 the first tried to find the bodies of those.
What been abundance in fundamen slant.
They buried them and the decorated with flowers.
Um,
the wooden crosses like this one that's marked individual graves on the
battlefields.
I would need to quote the French you let or French [inaudible] sent to his wife
my regiment as suffered terrible losses.
So it's,
it was written on Amish this day.
My Richmond,
I suffered terrible losses.
Many of my friends have been killed without ever knowing the joy of victory.
Thinking about those poor souls,
I feel terrible.
Those who are still waiting for news from members of their family,
we're still fighting.
Wanted first to be reassured before being able to rejoice.
Take the example of,
oh,
he folkard you,
uh,
volunteered in the summer of 1914 at the age of 35 and was fascinating
correspondence with his young fiance,
Madeline,
as been published just a few years ago.
Like Madeleine and I quote,
hi,
I'm,
I am longing now to have some use of Carlo of [inaudible] erode.
I will not be completely happy until then.
And those were lost strands.
Those were lost.
Brothers was with lost comrades in arms during the war,
often expressed what has been later diagnosed as the survivors syndrome.
The notion coins in the 1960s by Wiebe psychiatrist,
yet the lands and he would like to quote here Briola Rochelle in is not for the
committee.
The shallow work published just after the war.
At certain moments,
I experienced a kind of shame as vo had tone for days I was enjoying now from
those young men whom had left behind guilt,
shame,
anxiety,
sadness.
These were actually the feelings of most French solurs in November,
1918.
So that's the first circle of morning and sorry.
And this first circle of mourning was actually in close contact with a second
circle of morning violative of where frank,
where that comrades,
the soldiers as you may know,
use to inform the families of the precise location of the burial place,
including sometimes the photographs,
sometimes the man,
sometimes the description so that the body is could be filmed and rebury it
after the war.
He described the debt soleus,
last moments he described the funeral tribute that had been made actually in
doing so,
the first circle of mourning was small.
Primary group worked as a kind of fictitious family substitute for the relatives
were not present when the soldier was killed and the second circle of mourning
was composed of a Saudi,
his parents,
the grandparents,
the children,
the wife,
and also a larger family group,
uncles,
ounce,
cousins,
nieces,
nephews.
Most of the time I mess up meds if it's larger family group as being
underestimated because actually it appears in very rare sources and just with,
you mentioned one of his very interesting sources.
That's the war diary written by the young foss was in my head.
You probably don't know her,
but you know,
probably,
um,
uh,
name,
um,
when she will become one of the most famous child psychiatrist in France.
Foss was doled too.
So the young Francois has merit.
Uh,
I'd actually been indicated in a very Catholic family and she was brought up
with the idea that she should pray every day for her young uncle would have been
sent to the front.
So she had been brought up with the idea,
but in some ways it was her duty as a child.
And I will say as a young girl,
which is not the same as a young girl to do so and,
but it was actually a way to take part in the conflict.
And as you can imagine,
the death of earlier uncle adds a traumatic impact in the life of this young
force was my head's in a diary.
She repeats,
she presents herself come universe the gear as a war widow.
And the grief is presented as a personal tragedy.
So that's a certain circle of money.
And you've got actually a third one,
which is of course much more difficult to study,
which is made up of friends.
I don't know if you will be interested.
I think the story of friendship,
especially the story of friendship in war time is actually fascinating.
One which still needs to be written.
So if you have a senior essay to write about that,
it's a wonderful topic.
We sort of friendship in wartime and especially from the perspective of her
history of bereavements.
It has been only partially study for small group of students in the English case
for students from Oxford and Cambridge and in French case for students from
[inaudible] who lost actually hundreds of friends during the war.
And we used to write shoulds but very personal biographies in vehicles yearbook.
Take for example,
this arbitrary written by the novelist movies.
While you most probably know him,
he's one of the most famous writers of the Great War.
Um,
so it was written by the novelist movies who refer one of his friends killed at
the age of 25 in January,
2015.
And I quote,
what felt often during those long months of war and each engagement had created
voids around me,
all the good friends at the beginning.
Uhm,
I chosen what lightens my horse and to whom I wanted to give back.
The strength we have given me had fallen one after the one,
all of them until I was alone in a crowed of indifference men.
And among those whose support I wished for to make the skills of a debt were
fervent,
was been wa dearest to my heart and most valued friends.
I said to myself,
he at least will be saved.
And I believed it.
Then one morning in the white hospital room,
the mail orderly handed me a card.
And on this card I read butwhat is that I felt a crushing sorrow.
I could not understand it.
It did not make sense.
Well of course we substance of meaning bs absurdity can be explained by the
experience of war itself.
But it also leads us to the second point I would like to discuss with you today
the specificity if there is any of the experience of one the first specificity
according to me,
but for the first time death in combat reversed the normal succession of
generations are not on a limited scale rubber on the scale of a wound
generation,
lead generation pages,
the lost generation,
they were often feelings of shame,
feelings of guilt towards the younger men were almost exclusively bearing the
burden of war and death.
As my colleague Jay Winter pointed out in a thought provoking article on wartime
demography published some years ago,
many older people in Paris and London and Berlin were suffering from depression
during the great war.
And you've got the very famous case of the sociologist.
It need Ukiah w died of grief.
It died of grief only one year after his son's death in December,
1915 so the reverse of the normal succession of generations was seen as
shocking,
not only during the war,
not only in the immediate aftermath of war,
but also years later.
And I like to cook an amazing page from the last novel.
You probably know it.
It's,
it's one of the probably one of the most wonderful books written by Ldl Commute.
Uh,
Republic harm,
the first man,
a copy of which,
as you may know,
we'll stones in briefcase near the car in which the novel died in January,
1960 at the age 46 in 1950 free.
Albert made a pilgrimage to the cemetery in Brittany where his father,
uh,
lay it,
filmed the grave in the first row of the military section of a Sami share
cemetery at somebody,
you and there,
you read the date and I quote 1885,
1914 and automatically it did very frantic.
1929 years.
Suddenly it was truck by an idea of at shook his very being.
It was 40 years old.
The man buried under that slab,
what being his father was actually younger than he and the wave of tenderness
and PT that once filled his heart was not the steering of a soul that leads the
song to the memory of a vanished forever.
But the overwhelming compassion that's a grown man feels for an unjustly
murdered child.
Something here was not in the natural order.
And in truth,
there was no order,
but only madness and chaos when the son was older and the father second
specificity death was also experienced by the soldiers in a very solitary way.
Well,
it will tell me it's,
it's of course very common in what time.
But here it must be seen specifically in the light of both extreme violence of
the first world war and in the light of the religious rituals.
But we're still very important in France,
uh,
before the outbreak of world war,
one of the most striking fears experienced by the soldiers of the Great War was
of dying alone in the midst of a no man's land abundance by their comrades.
Because of the violence of a battle without a truce for a stretcher bearers or
because,
because the,
the shorts and official truces where too precarious solurs who fell wounded
between the lines lay dying for hours sometimes days.
According to the military historian John Keegan,
one third of the 20,000 men would died on the Somme.
On July the first 1916 might have been saved at the wounded soldiers being added
as we probably would have been half a century earlier.
So with fear of dying alone was something many relatives actually imagined for
the loved ones and which added of course another tournaments to Verbier
easements,
imagining their loved ones dying in an almost animal solitude was something.
And they're able,
and I would like to quote a war diary published 19,
19.
What we do,
he dies old alone over there like a dog and this horrible,
beautiful death we call death on the field of hunter.
He will lie for days and days forgotten on the bare earth.
We were smash skill and chest and German crows will steal away.
He's dearest memories.
Obviously we saw Richard death was over more and variable as dying was not the
socially invisible reality it has become in the late 20th century.
But something accepted,
something experienced at home.
It a company of ladies and friends.
And,
uh,
if you want to understand this process,
um,
you have to read the work by Slg snobbery alias,
which is probably,
uh,
his last book published in 1982.
The loneliness of dying in which he presents his process from,
you know,
once again the death experience at term to a kind of invisible solitary death we
experienced right now in it today.
So before one,
uh,
only votes,
what's new family on if those were new home will die alone or will die in the
hospital.
Um,
the funeral,
the funeral vigil was also very important and uh,
and a very respected ritual in a Catholic country like France,
industrialized warfare where one change this tradition in the most violence in
the most brutal way,
all the stages.
And they are very important.
All the stages,
the stages by,
but used to prepare a person for bereavement was simply eliminated all the
rituals in ordinary life accompanied with first moments of floss.
We're also eliminated.
The first specificity was the absence of for dead bodies during World War One
and that for,
um,
two main reasons.
The first one was the complete destruction of around 30% of those killed during
the great war whose bodies were destroyed by the explosions and could not be
identified in the context of total war.
Direc direct heats from large caliber shells cools,
literally pulverize the body living absolutely no remains.
Hence the green number of missing in action during the Great War.
If you want to understand the expense of shelling,
and if you want to explore to understand the psychological sufferings inflicted
the soldiers,
you must read what the Jesuits,
but you Bleuler a veteran of our don Rhodes about the battle of [inaudible] in
1916 and I quote,
when one heard the whistle in for distance,
once we'll body contracted to resist the two excessively potent vibrations of
the explosion.
And at each repetition it was a new attack in new fatigue,
a new suffering,
and the rest regime,
the most solid nerves cannot resist for long.
Perhaps the best comparison is that of seasickness.
And that's my point to die from bullets seems to be nothing,
parts of uh,
being remained in tact,
but to be dismembered,
torn to pieces,
reduced to perturb.
This is a fear that flesh cannot support and which is fundamentally the great
suffering of the bombardments.
But there is also under reason for the absence of dead bodies,
which is often less known.
After 1918,
the bodies remained on the battlefields until the French government's gave
permission to repatriate them.
But this dinner to happen before a special decree was passed in 1922 years after
the end of a one.
Why did it take some time to allow the French families to get their loved one's
body is back home for private burial.
Nobody knows.
But if the enormous amount of energy many French families spend to have his
decree finally signed,
shows in itself,
the psychological sufferings coast by distance and punch absence.
Well,
but something we all know from everyday life.
For example,
in the case of the sailors lost at sea or from recent events,
for example,
the victims of the nine 11 attacks ending the mourning process without having
seen touched or keystone birds.
A body is extremely difficult and most impossible and that's actually something
far dozens and thousands of families experienced afterward one,
but it's also something the French politician Luba to explain before the
national commission on military burials on May 31st,
1919 when the government,
French government still post the return of the Sardius remains and I quote,
fine,
it's all very well to say,
but our children will be equal in death,
but I don't see what principle of equality requires that a hard and fast rule be
established as far as feminism as concerns various,
my son was killed in 1914 five years ago,
is in a tomb.
His mother and I are waiting for him and because hovers,
I've not been filmed.
You tell me what you forbidden me to take my son and bring him to the Pella
share cemetery,
which is,
as you may know,
one of the largest cemeteries in Paris.
Well I tell you that you have no rights to do so.
You explain it by seeing that hundreds of thousands of Saudis I've been killed
and you have not identified them,
but mine was you speak of identification.
Well mine was identify of the transportation shortage but I can bring back my
son on my own without asking anything of governments.
This is not what I understand by quality and I think the proposed government
bill is a mistake but swipe I for my part won't accept it
as a consequence of the is specificities I've just presented.
The mourning process after one was an incredibly difficult and torturous Swann
and gave birth to a new commemorative activity,
new languages,
new rituals that I would like to present now in my first point up to now I've
addressed the notion of grief from the perspective of a personal Verafin's but
the expense of dust,
death,
the absence of so many dead bodies.
The violence of the war experience itself also needed new forms of
representation so that the dead soldiers could be remembered and [inaudible]
attribute could be bad to them.
That's what a stiff and underwent Rizzo and,
and it be care.
Explain in the book,
1914,
1918,
uh,
understanding of the Great War,
the words spoken at ceremonies the majors offered in inscriptions and
commemorative monuments,
the stained glass window,
cemeteries,
an ulcer is,
I've lasted to this day.
And through them we as historians can recall this endless commemorations where
political liturgy and private bereavements we're complimentary political liturgy
and private bereavements.
In other words,
collective mourning and personal grief.
My point here is not present to present you of course the wool of commemorative
activity after all one,
but we'll be,
unless impossible and use this.
I would prefer to focus on two major cultural processes,
but you,
we have a transformation of the personal grief into collective mourning.
The first one can be presented as a kind of a nationalization of mourning.
In the 1920s and 1930s,
the battlefields were converted into a commemorative sites through a network of
military cemeteries,
landscaped memorial parks and a large Butterfield moments.
It kind of water risen appeared during the conflict itself and develops in
Veneto and 20s and 90.
Third is,
uh,
just with Julia for if you're interested by that topic,
to Veeam,
to the book written by a David Lloyd,
a battlefield tourism pilgrimage at the commemoration of a great war in Britain,
Australia and Canada,
uh,
published in 1998.
This new sites of memory,
or to use the famous terminology coined by Piano Ha Wisnu [inaudible] memoir,
we're often represented on objects,
paintings and pictures.
And a number of ceremonies were organized via to pay tribute to the dead,
especially on armistice day each year.
And that's an object which I liked very much.
I mean,
it's a bit catch of course.
Uh,
but it's the also re,
uh,
in [inaudible].
So Nia Verda in Vietnam,
uh,
which is represented on a tray.
Can you imagine that to advance the term of the time anyway?
It's on entree,
uh,
and,
um,
you,
you see exactly what's what,
what's Demo,
uh,
Isabella,
I mean it's,
it's,
it's huge.
Necropolis,
um,
which was integrated in a summer 1932.
Uh,
it's a most at the same time to bring together most of the identifying but is of
a battle of symmetry here,
contains more than 15,000 buyers.
And the other aim was to contain the remains of those who remained unidentified
estimating them.
But here estimated 32,000 inside of the building,
32,000 Soviet Jewry,
uh,
which,
appears also in the famous 1937 remake of Jacuzzis,
uh,
by other algos where that third years here,
the symmetry rise from Motiva to rise from the grave in Duomo,
the Duomo cemetery to homes,
uh,
the living and prevent another war.
That's,
that's a fascinating film.
So,
um,
the author release Australia have dual moon and free of it once at [inaudible],
at Domo,
Vermont,
and at a Artman villa,
cops in the Alsace became places of,
uh,
family pilgrimage for those.
What's lost related or for those,
what's a new grave to go to?
According to me,
all this commemorative sites of memory must be considered in the perspective of
the French national unity,
the sites of memory,
which became sort of mourning for the wool French nation in this one demo.
And also the 36,000 war memorials built in each of the 36,000 commune into which
France was divided in every French coming.
So even if the very smallest village,
the same day of the year,
November 11th at the same hour,
11:00 AM the mirror used to name the debt for the lost generation,
a new entity was created but obeyed the classical precepts of tragedy,
unity of time,
November 11th,
unity of space,
war memorials,
unity of action,
the commemorative ceremony naming the dads serves.
As you can imagine,
another important function for the living inscribing the names of the debt,
reading them and then touching Vince corruption served to bring the dead out of
the anonymity of mass death.
And if you've been to,
uh,
Washington DC,
you know that it's exactly what happens nowadays with the Vm,
with the Vietnam Veterans Memorial in Washington DC main by my Alene where the
Vietnam vet school to touch inscriptions and more than that,
comrades in arms we over,
you'd be more,
if you have a site of memory related to this nationalization of mourning is of
course the commemorative invention by excellence of the great war,
the cult of your non Saudi in most countries except Germany.
And uh,
except Russia.
The kilt of your non Satya was extremely popular in the 1920s.
It appeared and must have the same time in Paris and London in 1920 in
Washington,
d c Rome and Brussels in 1921 and in Prague undergrads in 1922.
But of course,
I would like to focus on the French case.
What's happens in other managing 20 on November 10th,
1920 [inaudible] via known Sardius coffin arrived in Paris by special train from
Vietnam.
The coffin was placed for one night and every step is important.
The coffin was placed for one night at the plus.
Don't fair Horschel,
which is of course symbolic.
And you,
you know,
probably why?
Because it was named for [inaudible] was named for Herrick French commander of
1871 and so it's symbolized the revenge of the French have over Germans.
The next day,
November 11th,
1920 [inaudible] Sadia was broach to the podium,
which was first considered for national place to bury it because as you may
know,
it's the burial place dedicated to the nations.
Great man.
But according to most veterans,
the unknown Sadia was not I going on.
Tom was not a great man,
if usual meaning of a word.
So after a brief ceremony at the pointy on the coffin was brought to the
accurate [inaudible],
it had been drafts with the French flag had been placed on a gun courage,
and it was surrounded by mutilated veterans were there to symbolize the
destroyed man and we'll destroy families.
Furthermore,
and this is my point,
the coffin was also accompanied by a fictitious family,
a war widow,
a mother and father.
What lost a song and a child,
what lost his father during the war.
This as if each Frenchman,
each French woman was too doped,
Vietnam [inaudible] as a member of ease or earth family and the ceremonies of
November 11th,
1920 brought hundreds of thousands of weeping people and to the streets of
Paris.
Many and courage to believe that the coffin but past actually before them
contained the body of a man got lost.
In other words,
if you're non Satya was the debt relative of every French family as well as the
symbol of the loss experienced by the French nation as well.
So that's also a kind of nationalization of morning nationalization of morning.
But also this is the second major cultural process.
It kind of spiritualization of morning,
well,
I'll call you many examples of the spiritual favor that characterized for 1920
and 1930s.
I call look,
so discuss as Jay winter,
uh,
deeds remarkably in his book,
sites of memory,
sites of morning,
wherever the spirituality of the great war and of the aftermath of war,
great war,
something new or something,
a rooted in the European register.
Traditions and rituals only give you one emblematic example.
And actually I will end my presentation with beds.
This is a case of Marie Scully gots a portrait here.
Um,
a young officer cadets who died in Boucher van on the Somme on September the
25th,
1916 at the age of 22 actually,
it was sent on a record sauce,
uh,
mission.
And as it was just back from leave,
he probably didn't know the area very well and lost his way.
And he was shot by a German Petrol Morris.
Uh,
also the only child of bets and [inaudible] owns a factory in cane that's in the
department or the was close to Paris fettuccine methods for 50 kilometers from
Paris.
It was a marriage and only a few,
a few relaters.
His immediate family included Polis seven people.
And His death was of course experienced as a terrible emotional shock for all of
them.
Actually took almost six months before Morris galleys.
Parents received the confirmation that their son had been killed.
It was first considered missing in action and his body was identified only
spring 1917.
Becht Annmarie belts on.
And [inaudible] could not wait until the end of a war to see the place where
their son Morris was buried,
despite the obvious danger,
despite the restrictions imposed by the military authorities.
The drove to Bush ban in 1917.
Can you imagine that in 1917,
the drove to Boucher van as soon as we could.
And we took pictures of the temporary grave in 1922,
almost four years after VM is stairs,
but decided to Barry Morris for a second time.
[inaudible] his father wrote to the mayor of which oven and convinced him to
build a huge road site cross dedicated to the memory of a men of Boucher van and
dedicated to Morris himself.
So as you can see,
uh,
at this stage,
the personal grief is already deeply intertwined with the public collective one.
In 1922,
Beth Galle decided also to transform Morris's room,
um,
into a kind of off a mausoleum,
some grounds from the battlefield,
uh,
from the song was wrote back to Kay and exposed in a room along with,
I don't know if you can see that here.
Clearly we've,
uh,
fragments of showers and over material souvenir of the great war behind,
for cabinets window Molise Skelly's uniform with the Ruby red pants of 1914.
Some photographs here representing,
uh,
the young man,
so curious gathering of personal belongings and remains from the war,
which reveal according to me kind of finishes him,
but that's not all in this room transformed into a kind of chapel.
Morris was represented,
uh,
like a saint w at safety France.
And as his own grandmother wrote in a prayer,
the will universally,
they have to talk to you,
not only France,
you need to have to Dante Maurice's personal belongings were described Babette
by Beth [inaudible].
Uh,
his mother as some religious reliefs.
And this is actually what's many,
many Catholic French people throat either twenties and thirties.
At this time.
As um,
uh,
my colleague,
and because explaining it was one of a,
uh,
books,
the Christian soldier,
uh,
was lichens and his sacrifice to Christ in a kind of image ostial Christie and
his mother to New Virgin Mary and Mattel,
Mattel de la Rosa until a death in 1927.
Morris galleys over went every day to the room and we cited the prayer shut
composed for him,
thanking God for having given,
uh,
such a courageous grandson buskers of who we are,
the [inaudible] of the [inaudible] propelled him.
Or if we're able to,
paddy,
usually machine comas like a sane [inaudible] senior.
The prayer saves at the end.
Well,
when deeds,
the mourning process ends is the war of 1914,
1918 over as many photos in the early 1990s,
after the fourth of,
of,
uh,
will of billing.
Paradoxically in the last few years,
we have witnessed a new emotional investment in the conflict,
the first and the fourth generation,
but generations of the veterans,
grandchildren,
or great grandchildren.
My generation,
the new generation are more,
most,
more and more aware of importance of war in the story of the 20th century.
And the first World War tends to be evermore present in the minds of successive
generations,
according to mostly historians and accordingly,
especially too stiff and [inaudible].
We see a huge interest in the 1990s is related to the unfinished process of
mourning
and actually explains that by the number of mini missing in action in a one at
the end of 1920s,
after the death of Maurice's father Beth Galley decided to transform the house,
a service it could be transforming to a kind of museum.
So she was living in,
she moved,
she was,
she lived in,
in,
in the,
uh,
in a small house.
Just opposite,
uh,
what has become the Musee [inaudible] founded in the 1930s.
And she died in 1956.
Was this transformation of the house into a museum,
a way for her to show that the mourning process was over on the country.
Was it a way to prune the mourning process internally anyway,
after so many years,
Marissa's room remains unchanged as a kind of private chapel in a public museum.
Thanks.